let's just do that all right let's do it
man all right Elliot Elliot where are
you from originally I grew up in the San
Fernando Valley oh you're from L.A yeah
and you live now in Santa Barbara Santa
Barbara
and tell me about your family growing up
uh well I grew up a middle class family
mom was a school teacher and dad was a
electrical engineer and uh
you know went to the sort of normal
schools
um nothing super crazy in my childhood
you know divorce and drugs and the usual
kind of you know good times but I grew
up in the you know in the valley in the
late 60s early 70s and that was you know
we're all getting high right
oh uh how far are you in school well I
ended up getting a PhD in mathematics uh
and then I became a professor of
mathematics and did that I got tenure in
that uh gave up that tenured position
and got another one at UC Santa Barbara
and computer science and I was there
so yeah did a couple of University gigs
for about 20 years and uh then open a
little uh Consulting business for the
casino industry did that for about 10
years and and yeah brings me up to date
and you describe yourself as a Doomer I
absolutely am a Doomer
tell me how your
your education and your careers have
influenced your
stand as a Doomer well what I I notice
is that uh
there's a lot of people who
sort of over interpret information they
look at whatever the latest fat is and
they sort of go down that road and I
just thought I was kind of uniquely
positioned having a background in
mathematics computer science and
gambling right risk analyzing risk and
also a childhood I was a meteorologist I
I actually it's what I want to do
growing up so I just started
reading the papers and looking at the
facts and watching a bunch of YouTube
videos and and going to the actual
scientific journals and you know kind of
taking the whole spectrum of people who
are out there from those who are like
humanity is going to be extinct by 2026
to those who are like oh no there's
actually nothing wrong at all going on
right so the whole huge spectrum and
just sort of putting the evidence
together as best I could right and
especially you know realizing uh early
on that there aren't a lot of super
educated people out there like myself
who are on the Doomer side right it's
just it's very rare and so I instantly
my voice was sort of instantly
recognized in the in the area I have a
YouTube channel and a uh what is your
YouTube channel
um my YouTube channel is uh climate
casino at climate Casino
they changed it so it might be also at
climate disaster
um and my website is
climatecasino.net got it okay
and you've had this belief that we're
going to hell since when
um well really I mean the first memory I
have of it was in Ohio in 1983 or four
uh when Reagan was President we were all
uh
you know storing water in the basement
expecting nuclear war to break out any
moment I mean it's just I I've sort of
grown up you know with this
uh real dislike for Humanity for what
we've done to the planet you know
especially kind of the western version
of how we've operated and so you know I
lived in a teepee for a while when I was
in grad school and and um
I was vegetarian for a long time so I've
sort of you know I went to the Earth Day
in 1977 when Timothy Leary was speaking
at UC Davis so I mean as long as I've
been an adult really it's been on my
mind these General sorts of themes
would you describe yourself as a someone
who's negative or a pessimist in general
throughout your life
um or using like information I I
wouldn't say a pessimist uh I would say
a realist you know I've I I've been
around a lot of pessimists who just look
at everybody you know as everything has
a dark a dark motive and I don't feel
that way I I honestly feel there's a lot
of good people who are doing their best
and many are making you know doing
incredible things I'd single out Arts
and Music and medicine and science you
know and all the people involved in
those areas physics that's just to me
that's that's what Humanity's you know
goal was and and for me art is number
one of those and medicine is number two
because I think art is our purpose on
the planet to create Beauty you know to
to develop a sense of beauty and create
it and medicine's great because it makes
us a little longer time so we can create
more art right so for me that's one and
two but you know there are plenty of uh
of not so great things humans have done
too so I'm not really a pessimist I'm
just I I mean it's pessimist is like an
attitude I I'm more of a realist in
every way
I'd say
and what do you think we are destined to
see I mean what kind of things are going
to unfold here in the next well it kind
of depends on where you live on the
planet if you're in the Horn of Africa
right now in the sixth year of drought
you know you have a million people dying
of hunger today or if you're in Pakistan
where 30 million people got flooded out
last summer or you're in the bush you
know trying to be a koala in Australia
or you know 115 degrees in Argentina
last week and the latest prediction is
minus 50 degrees uh you know Fahrenheit
might happen up in Montana so when you
when you actually see in real time
disasters happening over and over again
and then you ask the question you know
kind of when is this going to happen or
how do you see this playing out it's
really just a question of understanding
it's already playing out right the the
collapse like what's happening in the UK
right now you know they essentially have
no health care anymore you can't get an
ambulance you know the Whole Health Care
system is collapsing they're they're
having hyperinflation you know so I
would say I would say uh collapse is
ongoing going it's beginning and ongoing
you know I'm not one like like a lot of
people want to predict they want to give
you dates they want to say here's a date
certain this thing will happen by then
but that's why I have the casino
mentality so what I like to do is give
odds you know I say the odds are this
thing will happen you know by this date
and so I actually uh you know flavor
everything with percentages that way and
uh for me right now you know I'm when
the Arctic loses its ice that's going to
be a bad year for the planet uh we're
gonna have some
major superheating going on you know
when we have El Nino happening uh
predicted for late 2023 then we're
talking about
um
you know breaking through that Paris 1.5
real quickly which means all these other
tipping points whether it's uh you know
the the weights Glacier down in
Antarctica or uh you know the Brazilian
Rainforest tipping into tipping so it's
you know
just becomes a grassland I mean all of
these things we are right on the edge of
all of these things right and the these
tipping points is not like just one
Tipping Point it's this whole sequence
of cascading tipping points you know one
one leads to the next and the next so
um yeah so we're right on the edge of
that right and when that process really
gets going
when the first big one hits right then
we're going to have this this uh series
of them yeah a series very quickly
unfolding and it's it's it's truly going
to be ugly for the planet it's sad I
mean my my thing is that it's sad I'm
just I you talked about a pessimist I'm
not a pessimist but I am sad I I'm
deeply deeply sad about the loss of
humanity the loss of human Legacy you
know all the beauty that humans have
created it's it's
it's a societal construction it's a
mental construction right but we still
appreciate it as Beauty you know my dog
doesn't think you know a song is
beautiful but I do right
so I really mourned the loss of beauty
and I I mourn all that humans have
created that is you know something that
that is a treasure that a mind is
capable of that
and losing that losing Legacy is what
makes me sad it's just the idea of
losing Legacy
was it was this avoidable no
no absolutely unavoidable at this point
no I mean at this point but was it
avoidable like like if if a hundred
years ago mankind well
no it was not avoidable as soon as we
discovered that we could use oil once we
found oil it was all over it was done uh
internal combustion burning coal you
know to Power Industrial civilization
1750 and and so I didn't realize the
damage we were doing them well it's not
that we're doing damages that we I mean
you have to use the analogy of the virus
and the petri dish you know you have you
have essentially
um
a thousand generations of humans staying
pretty much stable at between 500
million and a billion people right how
you were born is how you were going to
die there wasn't going to be a great
change in the standard of your living
during your life right if there was one
new invention every 100 Generations or
or 10 Generations that was a great way
to extend life right so once
um we got a hold of this food
right there's oil it's food it's free
energy for us and we learn how to turn
this free energy into stuff right and
into into vehicles and cars and and
Industry and and more people and more
buildings and everything that that's
destroying the planet once we got to
that point we're now we're now you know
10 15 Generations so we have a thousand
Generations where we were good to the
planet right now we got 10 where we've
completely screwed it up and you know
it's it's this is human nature when when
you know humans have been wiping out
species on this planet as long as
there's been humans around there's no
such thing as like a benevolent peaceful
species they're just species you know
they're just humans that haven't had oil
right that having that industry so yeah
when could we have stopped it if if we
had you know
somewhere around 1750
by some miracle never discovered oil or
what we could do coal
and there's no hope now oh no
no hope now it's the
what what are the biggest
problems we Face the Environmental
the climate
um well when you talk about problems you
know it's it's like what does the
problem do
um for many people the problem is food
you know we are uh talking right now
about 700 million people being uh living
lives with deficient food resources
um you know they're expecting that to be
well over a billion people by the end of
the decade that's the eighth of the
people on the planet under fed
undernourished it could be heat waves
you know it could be where you live
suddenly becomes uninhabitable uh due to
heat which could very well happen in
Phoenix it could you know could happen
in large parts of Africa within the next
couple years
um it could be drought which is what
we're experiencing here you know Lake
Mead is just five
um five years or so away five more
drought years from from essentially
losing the water entirely because it's
going to go Deadpool it's going to go
below the point where it can actually
drain and feed the lines so you know
once you have that you have mass
migration well once you have mass
migration you have people having little
uh you know Civil Wars because they want
to protect their Turf you know when
we're talking about internal migration
within this country you know let's just
let's just transport uh 20 million uh
Southern Californians somewhere in the
country go ahead tell me where you know
where are you going to put 20 million
people
so you're going to have a lot of civil
Strife civil
um you know a lot of
in the street fighting going on and you
already see that in lots of places you
know you're likely to see fascism
um come up you know we just barely
escaped it in the last election but you
know Russia was happening in Russia
right now is a typical example of what
you're going to see more of
um you know clinging to power cleaning
clinging to wealth when everything else
is falling apart you know what's
happening to Twitter with Elon Musk
right now is is you know he he is saying
things that are outright fascists you
know so it's it's this whole sort of uh
spectrum of things that are going to
fall apart it's not one single thing in
one place it's not the climate right
it's not
um food it's not population right it's
just it's just this whole
Spectrum uh and I actually have listed
40 uh different things that can happen
releasing new viruses is one of them
right volcanism is another one because
there's this stuff this thing called
isostatic rebound so as the ice melts
for example on Greenland right it
actually changes the gravitational field
of Greenland that's how much ice is
melting you you reduce that green weight
on Greenland by that much then then the
land of Greenland the underlying land is
rising up right because it doesn't have
the weight on it well that creates
pressures on the tectonic plates right
which creates more volcanism and so yeah
more earthquakes right so I mean there's
just unbelievable if you actually look
at the full spectrum of what's coming
down it's it's
all over the place
is it depressing for you
um it makes me very sad and I separate
being sad from being depressed and my
separation is that I am active every day
doing everything I can I I spend every
day doing everything I can a depressed
person doesn't do that they crawl into a
hole and and to say whoa is me you know
life is horrible
so you know I I have sort of a um a
mantra I go by in my life and it has
three prongs to it and the first prong
is
um service find a way to to serve your
community or serve the planet or serve
people in need do something to give of
your time you know to to help the those
in need to call attention to you know
whatever you can do uh the second one is
generosity we all don't have the funds
or the money or the ability to give
right but to whatever extent I'm able I
I try and be generous I try and be you
know give right and and uh even if it's
food or clothing or whatever just
constantly thinking about that and the
third is kindness and kindness just it's
exactly that it's like just take a
breath and be kind because there's no
reason to be anywhere else than kind at
this point in the collapse of
civilization in the cloud tops of the
planet there's no reason not to be kind
and I don't care who the person voted
for right I don't care you know what
their political views are I don't care
what their views are on the vaccine you
know I just don't care I want to be kind
to this person I fail at that one more
than any other I will freely admit I
fail my kindness test but you know the
the sort of Pinnacle theme to this this
activism is is this um
saying that if I can
um Preserve
the beauty of one flower for one more
day
than I've done enough right just just go
out today and think how you can help one
flower survive one more day
and if we all did our part we'd have a
lot more flowers but we're not going to
have a lot more days yeah
so it's it's just a terribly sad time
but you know there's this sort of weird
paradox
um and this was a Harvard study that was
2017-2018 where they said that um you
know when you preach hope when you
preach that optimism that we can fix
this so that we can do something then
when it ends up happening is that people
think well that means there's somebody
fixing it there's somebody doing it
right that that means I get a free pass
I don't have to do anything because hey
if we can fix it great it's being fixed
right so hope actually is
um
disinviting for people to
um be activists
it actually uh
sort of numbs people to activism
and it turns out that that the Doomer
message is the message of activism it is
the message of go out and do stuff you
know like like
um a friend of mine who just creates a
farm you know and his his activism is
let's grow some food and let's
um you know find places to to donate
this food I mean that's activism right
and that's that's not what a depressed
person does is say hey let me find a way
to spend my summer growing food so I can
give it away
[Music]
um
so yeah I am I am a hundred percent
um behind the notion that the reality of
where we are right now is a species and
in the history of humanity
um sort of should Propel us towards
activism but activism
um
as a humanist right not activism as as
I'm gonna fight big oil or I'm gonna you
know work for this political candidate
or I'm going to go plant more trees or
you know I'm going to go glue my hands
to a famous painting in a museum that's
that's not the kind of activism right
activism is saying I'm going to go
volunteer for the Wildlife Rescue and
help them you know clean the bird cages
right I'm gonna go
um help this non-profit distribute food
to to needy people you know the activism
means find going right to the place
where there is pain and hurt and and
suffering and doing something right at
that direct connection where you can
make you can see the difference you're
making right there everything else is
layers of abstraction away you go
fighting big oil that is so many layers
of abstraction away from what we're
seeing on the streets you know even
around here right that is that's miles
away but you go out on the streets and
you you give something to someone or you
help them with something entirely
different way to go through your life
and so that's that's what I preach
that's the activism and that's what
being a Doomer has given me is
discomfort that I don't have to be
political
discomfort that I don't have to worry
about issues that I don't have to engage
in fights with people that I don't have
to to be a
argumentative about things I can let
other people be right I don't need to be
right I don't need to get into to social
media fights I don't need to you know
argue I just I just act just act you're
definitely not the stereotypical
crazy Doomer I
you know I don't know that many doomers
but my experience and I I will say this
with my climate casino right because I
do a lot of odds
is that I set my lines for my Wagers
this is a weird world I live in it's my
history in the casino industry I set my
line for my Wagers assuming that all the
doomers are going to take make the worst
they're going to think it's going to
happen worse faster quicker than it will
so you know I I just put up a wager
um
recently about whether
um I thought uh the world would break
the Paris agreement 1.5 C in the year
2024. I'm getting about 80 percent
people saying yes right and I'm
I don't think there's a chance we're
going to break 1.5 C and that's like the
year after next right and so I see this
sort of among the Doomer community that
there's this tendency to think it's
going to be faster and worse and hard in
the next just one or two or three years
and then it's going to be done we're
going to be dead in five years it's you
know we're going to have one ice free
Arctic and then it's Doom we're all over
and that's not how it's going to play
out it's going to be slow and painful
and hard and it's going to be just a
terrific amount of suffering and it's
already beginning you know and and
you know I I think part of the reason I
I do this climate casinos I want to see
people uh get it wrong I want them to
get it wrong so that they will
understand that they are as doomers
you know airing
on on the side of of too much Doom which
may depress them which may make them
inactive that really when I said a line
I mean it that this is I'm trying to get
you to understand something about
physics and reality here
is it just human nature that we as a
species humans tend to self-destruct
um is it human nature that humans tend
to self-destruct
um I I think nature eventually conspires
on all civilizations you know there
hasn't been a civilization that's
persisted yet through the Beyond so
ultimately there is some reason every
civilization collapses
um I think this is the first time we're
going to have Global collapse of
civilization which means every
civilization everywhere
um there may be some holdouts you know
civilizations that are make it longer
figure out how to adapt I'm not calling
saying that the whole planet's going to
go extinct and many of these doomers
just they they will tell you oh yes we
will all be extinct in a couple years
it's crazy talk right
um and it's the kind of talk that keeps
you from being an activist right to
think oh yeah live for today do what you
can today enjoy you know one of the
things I often say is that um one of the
worst ideas Humanity ever came up with
is carpe diem live for today
and the fact that that's preached in
books and media and movies right and and
you hear people say it Carpe Diem live
for today that is
um the mentality of use resources
use resources destroy your environment
um you know buy toys buy crap do
whatever you can do today to take as
much as you can from the world for your
personal gain
and that's the exact opposite so when
when you hear Carpe Diem preach to
somehow a slogan of Enlightenment like
live for today as as if that should
entitle you to abuse the planet
um it is the it's just the exact
opposite of of the philosophy that I
have and yet it is the philosophy of
these near-term Extinction folks that
hey we're going to be dead in three
years let's live for today so I don't
know if that answers your question but
and so some some of us may survive there
might be a small percentage that
um I again I'm not one to
um
make per percentage guests but I do have
a wager
um my first Wagers the population will
still be over 8 billion in the year 2025
and I actually have somebody who thinks
it's going to be under that
um betting against me
and then I have a wager I believe
um I'm betting the population will be
under 4 billion by the year 2060. it
might be 2050 I don't recall in other
words I am thinking over the next 30
years or so we are going to have enough
Global catastrophe taking place that
there is going to be significant die off
of humanity but I would not go beyond
that 4 billion I don't have enough
information and it just feels Reckless
to make predictions without sufficient
information unless you want to make a
name for yourself by making predictions
like that and unfortunately a lot of
people do
so it'll be famine it'll be disease it's
going to be famine disease uh War
um heat
um you know yeah it's there are many
direct causes that that you can find
um
but I would say famine is the one that
is going to lead the way
and we could easily lose
three to five million people next year
in Africa to famine I mean easily if you
look at what's happening in Somalia
right now it's just devastating over the
top devastating
and and I give it's one of my Charities
is to give to these world food
organizations so yeah absolutely 100
heartbreaking
we're all more generous Kinder more
giving to each other do you think that
would
delay things or help or I don't I don't
have a solution for other people
um
it's the way I choose to lose my uh lose
my life that's a slip
um yeah lose because I'm 65 now right so
I'm losing my life actively over the
next 20 years regardless but um it's how
I choose to live my life and
um
there's I don't have a solution I don't
have something I can recommend to other
people you know it's um
it's everybody has to follow find their
own way through this mess
um and I'm not about to tell another
person
what they should or shouldn't be doing I
think the awareness of of our
predicament
the awareness of our predicament is
causing a lot of anxiety especially in
young people right now
and that's really sad to see that
happening especially people late teens
through their 20s they know they know
that by the year 2100 there's not going
to be Hong Kong and there's not going to
be Florida and there's not going to be
you know major parts of major ports
around the world are gone and and what
does that mean it means we can't have
shipping you know the major highways
along the coast will be gone okay so we
can't have Trucking you know along the I
mean we don't we can't rebuild this
infrastructure that's not happening and
even if we did we're trying to rebuild
it for conditions that are beyond
anything we can predict you know when
when all the roads get wiped out in in
North Yellowstone like they did uh last
summer how to even begin to rebuild that
because you don't know what climate
you're building things for you don't
know the building standards you should
have so so I think it's really hard for
the kids right now so I do think the
more they understand this um
predicaments the better choices they'll
make in their own life and many of them
are you know many of them are are all
ready for going having children
they're foregoing the idea of having a
long career they're trying they are are
choosing
um Lifestyles that give them more
experiences rather than more wealth
and
there there's a certain wisdom to that
that that accompanies their knowledge of
the facts that are going on right now so
so yeah everybody's going to choose
their own path but I think as this
information gets out and you know the
other half of that is you see the youth
the same youth
um becoming more activists in a way that
we haven't seen in 50 years absolutely
right and so the awareness of what's
going on with the youth is is beautiful
to see right and I support all of these
groups I mean Extinction rebellion and
and just stop oil and you know go for it
guys that's your path to deal with this
right not my path but it's your path and
I support them because
they're understanding the future and
acting and this is what I mean about
Doom creating action right
they are acting not because they have
hope but because they realize just how
dire the situation is right
it's a very interesting New World we're
living in
it is it's
um it is a sad sad world and it is one
that um
I mean it's so profoundly sad and
sometimes it takes my breath away the
the sadness I experience towards
what's going on and and you know it's
sadness towards humans fate but it's
really also sadness towards all the
innocent species
um that are are suffering from this you
know whether it's koalas and Australia
that are being burned alive you know
whatever wherever you are in the planet
you can find the species you know that
we're losing over a hundred species a
day are going extinct right now you know
20 times the background Extinction rate
it's just what we are doing to life on
this planet so yeah I I uh I see the
process
um reducing humans role on the planet in
the next
50 years or so fairly substantially
um
but I see the planet taking tens or
hundreds of thousands of years to to
heal from us so yeah this this Legacy
we're leaving behind is is going to be
very ugly for this planet for a long
time the planet would have been better
off without us
um
except for the art yeah the planet would
would have been better off with our uh
without us but I really love art and
music I I and
it it's so funny it's like when those
people poured the uh tomato soup on the
um Van Gogh or whatever it was
and my reaction was like look guys
anything else just not art just not art
right just not art
um so
some of them kind of agree with that but
it turns out about 75 percent feel like
art should be a Target because it draws
attention
so you know I said my piece
what would your message be to
people that are listening
um I would just say
pay attention more pay attention to all
the stories in the news that deal with
the collapse of the planet
there is so much out there right now
that on a daily basis even five years
ten years ago you just didn't see it
there is so much
and start educating yourself about
what's going on with not just climate
climate is one part of it but ecological
collapse the collapse of civilization
and make choices make your own life
choices understanding this is the future
and if I had my way
um including those Life Choices uh
choices to be generous and to be of
service you know
as much as you possibly can as much as
you can and
that's that's what I've decided to
devote my life to for the rest of my
life
great talk beautiful
Elliot thank you very much for sharing
your thoughts on all this thank you so
much I really appreciate you giving me
this chance
thank you very much